PEGI 18 Takashi Tokita Jacqueline Briggs  kung Jin you are not welcome here  sub-zero let's talk Cassandra you leave  this group but they do not follow until  you function as one you will fall short  our village was the epicenter of a  fierce battle at talisman with the  center jewel the Emperor grows desperate  and those caught in the middle pay the  price if this talisman is what I suspect  it to be we may all pay a price Pino  talked you know Molina's location had a  whole rebel army she  amulet that she's got a lot of  protection you took my the road now you  wish to steal my means of reclaiming it  okay guys standard diamond formation  Takeda you're on point Jackie bring up  the rear what makes you our leader is  that  don't know about you guys but I'm living  the dream  Earth realms fate lies with you  you